hey guys welcome to PI data I haven't
been here before so it's kind of weird
for me I've never seen this many coding
people with this much social like
walking around in forever I'm kind of
scared I'm not a data scientist I'm an
absolute physics PhD student but I
really wanted to come I wanted to come
because I need your help with my thesis
essentially I would be open about it I
need your open source libraries
I need your techniques I need your
advice and that's because astrophysics
has a problem we're told in school that
scientists form a hypothesis they gather
some data they find some results that
come to a conclusion in reality
astrophysics is drowning in a firehose
of data thanks largely to better
telescopes the amount of data we have is
frankly it's insane there's a radio
telescope being built right now that
will generate a petabyte of data per
second and that's ten times more data
than the entire Internet traffic of the
world so we have some data problems
we're talking about big data you're
talking about astrophysics
there's more to it though than just the
amount of bytes sometimes it's also
about the number of eyes you can put on
data so a little bit of science in the
early universe you have dark matter we
have hot gas gas condenses it's
attracted by the dark matter and it
forms the first galaxies for stars and
so on and for nearly a century
astronomers have been trying to work out
you know how exactly does this process
work and one of the ways to do that is
to
in two types you can have galaxies that
have undergone kind of mergers and
collisions that making a cameraman work
sorry so to remnant course so two
galaxies that are like halfway through
merging into one galaxy and that's sort
of how we think the universe forms is
kind of hierarchical accretion of
galaxies but the devil is in the detail
we're trying to work out quite how that
happens here's a catch a single modern
telescope can detect easily say a
million galaxies and there's telescopes
in the next generation 2020 or so you'll
be hitting billions our instruments have
outrun our eyes so most of the data they
collect will never be looked at by any
human being and that's the first time
that's true so let's get more eyes so
welcome to the universe this is the
project that I'm part of it's a website
for crowdsourcing scientific labels sort
of like Mechanical Turk for science
researchers upload the subjects they
need labeled and hundreds of thousands
of volunteers response volunteers are
transcribing the first parts of the US
Supreme Court they are counting penguin
populations and I'm talking to go like
literally penguin by penguin kids really
love that incidentally it's a great way
to distract your kids if you want to
just have some peace of quiet and of
course the label galaxy shapes all the
data we collect is open
anybody can upload subjects so it has to
be for scientific research and you
cannot make money from the hard work of
our volunteers so there's not a piece
you can't pay to join I'm not selling
something and of course we're not trying
to make money we're kind of happy to
talk about how it works in a way that
some of these commercial sites are
so I want to share with you a few
stories of our research teams have been
dealing with some analysis programs that
I think you might also face or at least
be interested by all or nearly all of
our analysis don't - I think you can say
on behalf of the science teams by the
way how grateful we are for the PI data
staff like thank you we literally
couldn't do our jobs without them so
don't focus people play there you know
after if I save my life thank you guys
the first challenge I want to talk about
is getting good labels so we think a lot
about data pipelines statistics machine
learning how often do we think about the
people who do the labeling that goes
into our motors and it's really
important because garbage in garbage out
if you don't have good labels your whole
job is gonna be much much higher so
here's a question if I have a subject
with many labels from many different
people disagree how do I estimate the
one true label so if we want to build a
model I need one value but I have
several dates this baseball team had
that problem so a little science detour
again gravitational lensing
gravitational lensing happens when you
have a massive galaxy the warp space
around it and a galaxy much more distant
behind it and the light from the distant
galaxy gets bent around the four
galaxies and you get these sort of
effects this is actually a galaxy twice
as far away directly behind almost the
elliptical galaxy where space-time is
bending the light almost like kind of a
magnifying glass towards us you know
that's a see galaxies that we otherwise
would never be able to detect
and that's really what's happening but
instead of glass it's gravity they're
usually quite difficult to spot so this
is a really obvious image but they're
not this obvious and volunteers
generally disagree about whether an
image is a lens galaxy or not and the
scientists had to deal with that those
conflicting opinions here's what they
did so they simulated some fake lenses
and they uploaded down as well now let's
say I'm a user on the website I'd be
looking through images some of which
were simulations been the labels and as
I respond to simulated images the
answers I give are recorded and used to
build a sort of a personal confusion
matrix for me so we're treating the
users like classifiers the same way that
we do usually from a Bayesian
perspective a confusion matrix is the
probability of an observation given a
model so the probably that I would say
lens given that it really is a lens for
example so that's why I've written it
maybe more formally than you'd be used
to and that means you can use Bayes rule
to combine classifications from
arbitrarily many people if you know
there are confusion matrices which you
infer using the simulated data that the
scientists have added so we start with a
prior lenses are rare ten to the minus
four ish so one in every four thousand
three hundred images ish will be a
gravitational lens and you can work it
out to some geometry when a user
classifiers an image
well update our belief in what we think
that image is using Bayes rule and using
the confusion matrix that we measure and
as classifications come in hopefully our
beliefs will converge to one side of the
other it's a log scale you can see
what's happening is they're galaxies
which we know do have lenses because
they're fake we simulated them and the
red is galaxies that we know do not
without us and experts look through a
small number to have kind of a golden
test set they separate so what we're
doing is we're taking the conflicting
opinions of different volunteers
measuring how well they perform what
they're confused by and we're updating
in a principled Bayesian way what we
what we think the best estimate of the
true level is and once we're
sufficiently confident you know we'll
retire the circle okay good we're done
we have a label for that we can move on
that lets us be a kind of Bayesian Big
Brother so now we know all the confusion
matrices for our volunteers we have to
see how people behave this plot shows
the diagonal elements on the confusion
matrix so if you have probability that I
say it's a lens given that it is a lens
and the probability that I say it's not
a lens given it not a lens the line
through the middle is so random each
point is a volunteer it's like a random
sample of 200 or so happily gdpr I'm
allowed to do this represent how many
images of volunteers see variation so
people find this difficult and people
find it difficult in different ways it's
not clear the people are like always
positively biased say that's not really
true which means it's kind of modeling
approach is quite important to get good
labels kind of a drift to getting it
right people are hopefully learning the
more images you see the big with a
yellow dot the more astute you are the
more you're getting your large dangle
element so that means people using the
website really are learning how to
classify gravitational lenses in
scientific data and I think that's kind
of cool
on the whole people are improving and
giving us good labels means the
scientists can do spectroscopy on these
lens galaxies once they're published
they can follow up and we were trying to
find out what are they made of how did
they come to be so supporting science
but the Bayesian method kind of realize
you know some true labels to begin with
and that's not always the case
it also requires you be other
constructed confusion matrix also not
always true so for me I'm technical need
of the Galaxy Zoo project where we're
classifying shapes of galaxies and
across all the questions there's about a
hundred and forty possible responses
it's kind of a decision tree we lead
people down and it's not easy to turn
that into a confusion matrix and if we
did it would be super sparse
we wouldn't get enough data to say how
excuse it behaved
to be very stochastic we had to try
something else so what we do and this
isn't something I came up with something
other smarter people came up with is to
reward consistency so if I generally
agree with the crowd then I'm doing a
pretty good job now
crowds can't get things wrong as we've
seen in certain recent electoral moments
but on the whole it is a very good way
of discounting bad actors so the way it
works is you calculate your crowd
predictions naively everybody waited the
same you measure how often one
particular person agrees and if they
agree with the crowd then up wait them
and if they don't down with them and
repeat and you kind of iteratively
converge on a consensus where hopefully
people who consistently disagree are
automatically removed turns out that's
kind of useful so we give volunteers the
option of selecting artifact which skips
the next image we work with real data so
sometimes the images are genuinely bad
maybe a cosmic ray your telescope
detector stuff like that however people
are known as well behaved as
scikit-learn
that sometimes I wish I could submit
pull requests to certain people working
on that here's what I consistently
measure shows so this plot is by dr.
Stephen down through each dot is a
person there's maybe 50,000 people on
this plot if you look closely on the
y-axis is how consistent they are with
other people
and you can see this kind of two
distributions the more consistent you
become so we hopefully infer to me and
that means people are learning they tend
to agree with each other more guys
no matter how many classifications they
do they don't become any more consistent
in fact arguably become less consistent
and this is a log scale so this dude
this dude has done 10,000
classifications and he's almost the
worst guy and it turns out if you color
by consistency they're clearly separate
and this is how often sorry if you color
by how often they press the artifact
button in other words the skip button so
what these guys are really doing is
they're flicking through the pretty
images and they don't really care that
they're messing up our data they just
want to see pretty galaxies so that's
the kind of stuff you have to deal with
the real people sadly the world is a
little messy but the consistency deals
with that pretty well and they're
automatically down weighted so depends
which project so the galaxy's new
platform doesn't yes I joined about six
months ago that's something I really
want to implement but some projects do
the one I showed previously there the
one with simulated gravitational lenses
they had kind of a training phase where
they'd show you a very high proportion
of simulator lenses and they give you
feedback when if you got it right or not
and then as you as you became more
capable they'd show you less simulator
ones and they kind of trust you're doing
a good job they already have some
estimate of your confusion matrix and
they just check in every now and again
so yeah we do do feedback and it's
really useful
absolutely
I'll put a give you a website on Twitter
later you can just you know view the
whole and all the data we use is from a
lot of it is from open telescopes
they'll have download services you guys
can use its data professionals but maybe
just to view the sky it's kind of fun
I'll send it around on soccer or
something that's good way so that's kind
of a couple of things we found useful
for getting good labels you treat each
person as a classifier with the
confusion matrix and update your belief
or if you can't frame the problem that
way then at least you can consider their
consistency get rid of the that's how
galaxies do currently crates labels now
this is a data science conference you
all know where this talk is going we
have a large set of data most of which
is labeled but a lot of which is not
what are we going to do yeah we're gonna
build a machine but it's not some keggle
challenge I need to do this to finish my
thesis this is important guy so earlier
this year my supervisor Chris told me
here's 250,000 galaxies
I need them classified when you've done
those two or 50,000 more waiting and by
the way there should be a fairly short
project there's other things to do
should give you about a year I did the
math and this is how fast we're getting
through galaxies currently and this is
how fast we need to be getting through
characters currently on average by 2019
in order to be on track for my thesis so
I really need to build this thing that's
the good part the bad news has a problem
by the way I meant that I have a problem
the bad news is this
so there's a telescope called LSST being
built it will image an order of
magnitude more than anybody else's
Everyman's with galaxies and my job is
to deal with that data through our
website and for that to work this is how
well we need to be doing so some work to
be done so this is why I need your help
I wasn't kidding
so I have a bit of a problem you're
gonna do a bit of a little not really
math but a little little detail now this
is the first sort of deep learning you
talk and I noticed on the schedule that
Sunday's pretty packed with them I think
you might hear a deep learning once or
twice more in this conference so I'm
gonna just spend a minute recapping how
the method I use works convolutional
neural networks it's a really good kind
of become the de-facto algorithm for
analyzing images and although you can
use a lot of simple packages like Karis
pie talked to me more fiddly thanks to
flow to deal with this stuff it's good
to know how it works even if you almost
don't have to anymore so just recapping
quickly so we have an image you want to
classify it we're going to image a set
of matrices will convolve with it called
filters and the elements in those
matrices will be the weight of a neural
network and they'll be shared across a
layer and that's what makes it so
convolutional all the weights in one
layer I need to be the same if you do
that several times what happens is with
each convolution you will highlight
certain features say edges and as you
repeat it you'll be building up an
increasingly abstract feature map of
what is in the image so as opposed to
say around and forest will you start
with a set of columns you have
well-defined features in images you're
trying to learn the best features and if
you change the scale of convolution in
practice you're really shrink the sort
of post convolved image each time before
you feed it into the next step then
you'll be checking increasing the scale
that you're picking features out see if
you like your first
finding edges and things in small
regions and as you build up you'll find
you know say a spiral arm across half
the image your visual cortex is sort of
telling you what is in the world and you
can list off those features and put it
into fully connected layers more about
your intelligent perception like given
what I know I'm seeing a bunch of people
in the room what does that mean and you
hope that will correspond to a good
prediction for what type of galaxy is
this is that a spiral galaxy is
elliptical and so on the reason that all
of it works the reason you know the way
we're gonna set all of the three
parameters all these weights and biases
all throughout the network is by showing
it showing the network and image
measuring how wrong we are according
some cost function and then slowly
iteratively changing those weights so we
would have been less wrong and repeat
and we hope that the weights and biases
we learn will generalize so that when we
show a new image our prediction will be
better and that's really what training
is and when people talk about back
propagation and gradient descent that's
what's going on back propagation is just
a mathematical trick to start from the
answer and work back to what each of the
weights should be without having to do
too many second derivatives that's
really I want to tell you one other
thing first before we get back into it
so you've probably heard of drop out so
drop out is where you remove temporarily
a random set of neurons from the fully
connected layers and you you require
that you still have a good prediction at
the end so this happens during training
there's two ways of thinking about it
either you're trying to reduce the
dependence on any one particular neuron
so you still get good predictions you're
not too sensitive to a change in the
weights or bias of that
or seen another way you're training many
neural networks and you're kind of model
averaging them so it's like decision
trees to random forests if you if you
have very slightly very classifiers and
you take some ensemble you generally do
better that's kind of another way of
seeing it and that idea that we're
training several models is going to be
useful later so that's the scaling
science intro I don't want to go so the
way the rest is thought could be is this
is how I do it this is how we now use
deep learning we'd have better
predictions look how well we do it
classifying galaxies I could do that I
think it wouldn't be the most
interesting talk and I think it wouldn't
be the most interesting thesis so I'm
gonna kind of jump to the next level for
a bit you can kind of trust me that we
have a model that works and I say okay
what can we do with that that's cooler
than just predicting some galaxies let's
go one step further what happens if we
can close the loop so if we have good
labels to help humans give us better
labels and we have to assist how the
website works can we have a way to first
example I give as a way to kind of
ensemble the Machine predictions and the
human ones I said before we treated
humans as classifiers in one way now we
really are using them as pacifiers we're
gonna try and combine to do better so
there is one cool example by Dowell
right at Minnesota so these are pictures
of what we called transient events
things in the sky that changed rapidly
galaxies basically static forever
they've been around for billions of
years there will be for billions more
and although they collide and so on
nobody would ever live long enough to
notice really we only catch these things
as snapshots this project was looking
for supernovae which are interesting to
scientists under
particularly distant scales you want to
measure how far away something is a
supernova is a good way to do it because
particular types of always the same
brightness if you know how bright
something is you can infer how far away
it is that's why it's kind of useful so
we have this project where you show
different images of the sky over time
one of these is a residual kind of to
help people find the difference and ask
does it look like a supernova and Daryl
did something quite clever I think so
he had his labels from the volunteers
and kind of put them aside and
separately he gave his dataset to
experts the experts also classified some
different data same images better split
and train a convolutional neural network
like I showed you so you have an expert
trained model and the human labels
visual on something obviously that's
smarter way that just is a straight up
you know way to show it in your
presentation you can separate your data
much better if you have your expert
classifier and human labels kind of
working together
humans that are beyond about point free
just to save people's time you can see
if you wanted to separate out the real
supernova the red dots just using the
x-axis but when we add in the human
labels you can do a much better job of
kind of separating out this space the
humans and the expert train model can
kind of outperform either one alone if
you were to just take human labels and
just train the model and then just use
those predictions you would do worse
than this method
so Ashley physics has a problem I have a
problem my problem is to do with how do
I show people the best images so if I
only have a certain amount of volunteer
time but I have many more galaxies than
they could ever look at I'm going to
build a machine learning model but I
want to give it the best possible
training data and I only want volunteers
to look there for the most useful
galaxies to my model I want to select
the best galaxies to get labels for and
it's kind of a common problem any time
getting labels is expensive and gang
labels is always expensive in some sense
it's time and cost the number of people
you have to hire whatever here's kind of
a nice way of doing it let's say I'm
training though it's been pre trained on
on the project and I would have
volunteers look at them fast by these
1,000 images on which the model isn't
most I'm so add them to my pilot
training subjects
the hard part for me is is finding out
which in what would mean by uncertain so
if you have say a binary classification
problem that's kind of trivial right the
equals 0.5 is the most uncertain things
really I have kind of the regression
problem I want to say which what is the
vote fraction the number of volunteers
out of all the volunteers who would give
this answer everything is really only
continuously and I want to keep that
aspect because some galaxies really are
ambiguous some people really do disagree
our images are only so good and teachers
can be unclear we might genuinely not
know but when scientists come to use it
later it's an important distinction to
keep because you can imagine a scientist
making kind of a bootstrapping effect if
if I want to say if they do galaxies
with spiral arms look bluer it matters
which galaxies have spiral arms and if I
know the confidence well I know that
vote fraction well then I can sample and
get an uncertainty measurement on my
color versus spiral miss relation so
that will help people to preserve but
it's tricky so the way we do that and
the way we hope to do that is with
Bayesian neural networks so the reason
that before and the idea of its being
training many models it's going to kind
of connect with the idea kind of
variational auto-encoders certainty it
turns out that doing many forward passes
at test time instead of women as well as
when we train but also when we're
testing on an on an image to get a real
prediction out is in the continuous
limit equivalent to Gaussian process
it's like training many models and
seeing how much their predictions will
vary and using that to get some
confidence limit on what our prediction
will be so we kind of hop between do
this a few times on a forward pass of
test time and see what's the confidence
of my prediction and if you were to take
those forward passes and put it more in
the sort of statistical language of so
Gaussian processes we're kind of
assigning distribution to each of the
ways in the network instead of having a
single scalar or scalar weight
distribution and that's what so is my
answer so that's going to give us more
of an idea about if things were slightly
different what would we say about the
image so I'm hoping to use that to pick
the most uncertain images in a more sort
of principled way and in a way that I
think is a bit novel we'll see if it
works come back to the conference next
year and we'll find out this is kind of
gotten to the point that you know this
is very what I'm going to go back to my
computer and work on I think it's kind
of neat and I think it's kind of cool to
see how the techniques that we're
developing are sort of coming full
circle well we can have
human-in-the-loop training so it's kind
of different to work in a jupiter
notebook and build models as to work in
a production system where you have tens
even hundreds of thousands of people and
some control over what you ask them to
do so humans I think in the future will
become more of a part of the way we do
machine learning and the way we build
models and I think that that's probably
a good thing but I think that there are
important things for us to think about
when that happens
I want to show you this is the splash
screen of a major commercial
crowdsourcing website which I work named
for legal reasons but I might mentioned
it earlier so maybe you can infer they
say human intelligence through an API
and I think that that kind of misses
something I don't think you can reduce
intelligence to HTTP GET right what they
mean is labels they mean answers right
this kind of marketing and we found that
the Zooniverse were kind of privileged
in the problem we work on it's
interesting people care they talk about
it there's kind of a curiosity to it and
we found that our best discoveries don't
come from the labels that people give us
they've come from people talking about
what they see in the data because they
at this point looked at more galaxies
than I have even that guy remember he's
seen more galaxies than me and I'm an
astrophysics PhD student at Oxford right
so maybe if you'd actually paid
attention to them anyway that's a
question and maybe he'd be able to tell
me something about something he'd seen
people have discovered planets there's a
planet around the first planet ever
discovered to be in a in a double binary
system so two stars two stars planet in
the same solar system was discovered by
people chatting on our forum about data
that they see there's a huge ionized
cloud of gas you know in a galaxy that
was discovered by somebody who's being
like hey what is this weird green smudge
and it turned out the green smudge was
hot oxygen being ionized by the
radiation coming out of the sort of
supermassive black hole in the center of
the galaxy as it beams through ionized
this pocket of oxygen and we can see it
in our image
that's kind of common we found twenty of
them now so this person discovered a
whole new kind of astronomical object
just by having somewhere to talk about
it and looking at a stupid number of
galaxies
so I don't think we should phrase it
like this I think we should try and keep
the humans able to feed back to us the
modelers inhibitors not quite that
dramatic you guys know the importance of
being close to your data when you're
trying to construct features when you're
trying to interpret what you find we're
trying to communicate that and the
humans in your system might know more
about that than you think so even if
you're not doing a science project not
doing something people are naturally
happy to chat about you should think
about building a structure where people
can talk about that well they have an
incentive to do so where you reward
people for giving you good insights and
I think that that would be better for us
as modelers and better for them so
that's kind of my suggestion science is
not quite the same as data science we
find it really hard to be agile for
example you want to run an experiment
for a while you don't want to change
things fast right every time you change
something you make your life 10 times
harder because you have to compensate
for it later and then suddenly you're
stuck in a data analysis for next six
years you never write your thesis and
I'm totally not worried about this at
all but I think that we have a lot to
learn from you guys in terms of building
models and I hope that this presentation
has you negated something that at least
makes you guys interested in data
science for science and if you want to
chat more about that Thanks
[Applause]
any questions yeah
Brandon now cigarettes oh don't hurt me
proud so they don't really tell us what
they do because what they do to be smart
about aggregating the labels of
different people is their commercial
edge and I'm sure Mechanical Turk and
the other services do the same so the
only reason I can talk about this is
that we're not making money so I find it
really hard to compare because they
don't publish papers about what they do
I know who this is the like to animal
talk in their room the podcast they had
they've had a few episodes of figure
eight in the last few times and I
noticed that they're they're scientist
was kind of saying yes he paid this time
to come out but really we're at the
cutting edge and you really have no way
of verifying what they're doing at all
so we're just gonna have to trust them
so we'll find out yeah
I think in terms of the model building
of a lot of parallels of medical imaging
we have quite complicated messy images
potentially quite small numbers of them
we want to infer something about it that
tends to get into medical imaging and
uncertainty again the same medical
people are really concerned about I'm
not sure I think what we'd like to do is
if you have a radiology problem chuck it
on the platform and we'll see what we
can build so we're quite happy to
particularly use cases if there's a
genuine need especially if you have some
science funding to share
1,200 aggressive you have some very
aggressive data augmentations so if you
know they're in variances you can
exploit them like with galaxies if I
flipped if I rotate by zoom in cross etc
that I should get the same answer maybe
isn't the main specific stuff like
adding class or noise or a photon
counting detector then it turns out
these methods actually work you know
pretty well think about the like hot dog
hot dog a pretty car alright how many
folks do you think they took pictures
over to do that probably know that
you said that you are that the amount of
galaxies are you are classifying at the
moment and amount to the amount of
galaxies that you need to classify is
quite there is quite a difference what
do you think are your bottlenecks so
much even if I could have you know
everyone in the world would spend five
minutes a day on my website maybe I
wouldn't want to do that right if I
could be smarter about it
maybe I should only show them the things
that I really need to know about so
that's my bottleneck really it's not
computational it's just the amount of
labels just a quick question so when you
actually get the distribution of your
your certainties so to speak how do you
classify if that distribution is or how
do you exactly threshold that to say
that oh this observations more uncertain
versus surgeons I think it becomes a
pure statistics problem right you have a
distribution you'd like to quantify your
uncertainty in it around
I think that I would like if you have
your mic you can estimate you can
estimate confidence interval and you can
set your confidence interval to have met
you like and really that's one way we
can talk about entropy and amount of
information in the distribution that's
another way but that's kind of now
outside of this machine
[Applause]